um
there's this the double xl freshman
cover that's going on right now there's
a voting and all that [ __ ] like
like uh do you feel like you deserve a
slot on that cover oh yeah definitely
especially since like you know what i'm
saying like i barely did like i don't
know like last year i was i was
i was in chill like i was chilling you
know what i'm saying because i was still
dealing with the police and stuff
right so like and i and like i got two
big records that like was
like you know what i'm saying that's
going crazy right now i still got one
batman
like you know oh yeah no by the way you
you you i you got me like a custom
batman
you know versions you're looking out on
that you know what i mean i appreciate
it now yeah the batman joints going
crazy how did you link up with 42 doug
uh i was i was recording in miami i want
to say back in 2019
i was at circle house recording um shout
out to circle house
love that place yeah that's like one of
my favorite studios you won't even know
it's a studio it's just it's like a
mansion
yeah what it is though like you know
what i'm saying they got different rooms
yeah yeah
but yeah so boom i had no um i was
recording down that circle
and i hadn't just signed my deal with
the interscope and
chameleon record you know i'm saying
they brought him and it was like um
i was in a recording he was like man i
got this this um young cat from um
detroit he's here with gotti cause i've
been new gotti yeah of course i'm saying
before i signed my deal so he was
telling me got it i'm about to pull up
he was like he got his artist with him i
want you to [ __ ] with him i'm like all
right i'll check him out you know what
i'm saying i never heard of the uh
42 dog around this time so when he
walked in i'm looking at him like damn
he looked he's shorter than me so i'm
like yeah i'm just the last kid
and you're you're pretty short right
yeah yeah hang on i think it's smaller
than me
yeah i think he's smarter than everybody
respectfully
yeah you know i [ __ ] with him though i
saw the video of james harden bending
down to talk to about the sidelines the
other day i was like damn
so i'm like damn i looked at him like
damn all right i'm gonna [ __ ] with him
so they pulled me out in the hallway he
was like man this [ __ ] spit you know
what i'm saying so i don't want you to
show up oh yeah definitely i know i am
sorry
so i went and picked the beat you know
what i'm saying i picked the beat i
think with the first beat i win in my
thousand pull up
it was like a like some like turn type
[ __ ] so all right i put it up
he went to bobbin head to us i said you
[ __ ] with it like yeah that [ __ ] walked
in the studio
just went to spain we had them
freestyled i think we did a song in like
45 seconds what 45 minutes i'm tripping
say 45 seconds the song is like no no
it's longer than that
bro went in there no bro hat went in
there and went crazy a lot he he went
and dropped his look like i think he did
an eight
at first or like he i did his first
eight and i'm looking
and all this in the studio shot like oh
[ __ ] you know what i said [ __ ] rap and
my daughter was like i was telling you
this [ __ ] who made uh dog food
right no yeah that's him now so i
wouldn't do my thing that's how that
came about you know